the things that i love the most in our  kitchen because when our kids were  little they would always be want to be  with mama mama mama so i could set them  up here either with their little art  project or just sit here and they would  always just sit and talk to me and i  think that that is like some of my best  conversations with my littles  um when they were there so that was  really cool  um the other thing that we did was we  did this giant refrigerator freezer so  if you can see it's like as wide as my  wingspan so it's six feet wide  for a freezer on the side refrigerator  on the other side  this has all of our  basic food somebody else put the  groceries away today otherwise it would  be much neater but  mom knows me  and then this